it's the fighter and the kid had to run
it back cause we back at it again yeah
we gon keep it moving like it's never
gonna end when it was brendan when it
was brian when he was just talking to
friends we got the kid calling on the
left with the fighter on the right had
to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is really the fighter in the kit
we're out come on baby
okay chad here we are ladies and
gentlemen another episode of fighter and
the kid another another one another one
now i had to take two planes
to richmond virginia is a nice town
nice town the east coast i i need to
explore the east coast a little more
because everywhere up on the east coast
there's some nice part now i can't get
dicey some parts yeah but
new york yeah yeah even virginia a
little dicey on richmond virginia is a
beautiful town always has been college
town very good yeah richmond right
really good school yes
and they're
hotter than the sun what i what i what i
forgot about the east coast is that when
you walk out in the morning you hear
all kinds of animals birds everything
you just hear go go go go and where
you're at yeah but in virginia you know
the east coast is a very rural part it's
very green
i could live if there was if there
wasn't winter yeah
just the winners out there miserable
they'll break your back sir uh not for
now to break your back daddy's out
especially boston especially up there
where when i'm when i tell you in
january yank walking around
with your face
exposed yank
i went and did lap boston in january
they were like where's your scarf oh
yeah
yeah i tried to walk a mile no i tried
to walk a half a mile and i too much i
darted into a [ __ ] first store and
you tap out tap out it was you're
rushing you couldn't feel my face red
robin just to get correct from the air
anything no i've had the
like where was i yeah buffalo was
freezing this is my thing so in boston
right they have a in new york too like
mafia and boston they had whitey bulger
like yeah i assume they just shut it
down in january well even whitey
bulger's like
yeah let's
let's get to february but you know let's
not do any deals during january yeah but
they do but they [ __ ] do the east
coast keeps on so tough ah that's why
they are tough that's why they're more
aggressive on the east coast they're so
much more expensive
i i actually have i'm probably
completely wrong i actually have a
theory on this can be terrible i have a
theory on this when you go to boston you
go to philly you go to boston let's just
take boston you go to a bar
i feel like i am by far
the thinnest
weakest person in that bar their their
aggression in the air and the winter
forces you to develop an extra layer
they did a study like russians what's
that it's like russians yeah you look at
so many from russia like they have just
this
extra layer of life yes and there and
like they did they were they were
wondering why a lot of men in prison
even though they eat a lot of starch and
the food's not good but they get really
thick without steroids they get big big
big
what they the theory the working theory
is interesting which is
when you're in a situation where it's
dangerous all the time heightened it's
aggressive your testosterone is spiked
all the time oh
constantly
so when you're in an extreme environment
like that you're [ __ ] testosterone is
always at 11. you're yeah so you're
always so when you lift and you eat you
just get it's your body's naturally
making more testosterone you're always
in combat you're always war you never
know you always have to be ready you got
to always be ready well i'm gonna
dethrone this theory then why is new
york so woke
up because they're the locusts because
they got a [ __ ] load of money and you're
talking about the one percent when you
talk
brian when you talk about new york
you're talking about the elite 1
you're talking about it's an
international city by the aristocats yes
the original new york the new yorkers
that built new york that were new york
that was a very different uh thing
very different thing yeah and the woke
got power and then turn the city upside
down when you're very wealthy then san
francisco said hold our granola same
thing watch this so when when silicon
valley so the people who made silicon
valley were just a bunch of dudes a
bunch of guys who are probably
nerdy but very smart and and had a lot
of testosterone they couldn't put it in
anything but
you know building these crazy they were
they were outlaws they're crazy and and
that's what kind of built that that's
what made that city so ridiculous but
again
hard times make
strong men strong men make easy times
easy times make weak men yeah and
and you know it's it's [ __ ] when you
have everything when you have all that
money when you have become soft well you
also are able to
worry about things that don't really
matter
or yeah you're right and like in the
grand scheme of things let's be honest
like go go tell ukraine your problems
right now let me know like wait what
yeah you're upset about what that's
right
that's right
that's exactly right
yeah because once you're at the top
that's when you can get up there and
you're worried about stuff that really
isn't that important to the masses it's
more of an interview think about think
about them think about most of us we're
all working really hard to build a
business and make money we all have to
constantly work to make money i know a
lot of people have they have money but
you never it never ends how many people
you know they could stop working
two two i think about that today i know
too do you know anyone here just stop no
i know two no because somebody a little
stressed about money like planning which
you know i have planned stuff like that
but it's like and your business manager
goes you want six months where if [ __ ]
hit the fan you're good for six months
i'm like yeah no doubt we have that but
it's like but what if it's like two
years and he goes uh we have like .01
percent of clients who are good for two
years of no income no worries
that's unheard of you need so much money
yeah well you'd have to live in a little
hovel
you can't the the problem is when you
start making money your nut gets bigger
and so there's no there's just no
[ __ ] waste you've always got to be
working but
if you look at it's really interesting
because if you look at the the woke sort
of the woke where the wokeness came from
which is these universities it didn't
come from poor people and it didn't come
from people who work with their hands
and it didn't come from people who have
been in the military and it didn't come
from people who came from work
it came from very cushy wealthy
academics highly educated people who had
a lot of time to sit around and think
but i think it's really interesting too
because when you talk about like if you
actually look at the agenda of the work
whether they know it or not the reason
they talk about marxism so so the idea
is if you actually look at the woke
agenda it's really about tearing down
the power structure that exists correct
and the only way to do that structure
the only way to do that yes the only way
to do that is to say uh that the power
structure is is only one thing it's like
it's a white tyrannical
patriarchy
okay
but the only way to make change and karl
marx said this who created you know
communism everybody
he said that the biggest enemy
to revolution
is the faith is the faith
okay good you're trying you're trying i
throw out ideas because you can't read
that book right you're trying but he was
the guy who said religion is the opium
of the masses and he didn't like
religion
why
because what is christianity as an
example he was probably talking about
christianity what does christianity do
well it's not going to foster revolution
you're judging people too well no also
but as a christian or say you are say
you you are immersed in the christian
faith or at least that's your culture
the idea is that yeah shit's not good
for me but i can bear my cross there's
meaning and suffering the meek shall
inherit the earth
strengthen this life jesus
my sins all that yeah so i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna go kill my
boss or tear down the factory
so mark said
well as long as you have the faith like
that you gotta kill god because
otherwise and because people have to be
so angry and and and godless they have
to be angry enough to tear down
society and rebuild it
to create what heaven on earth a utopia
interesting
yeah i'm not woken up i was uh
supposed to do this venue i don't say
the venue name i told you this let's do
this venue so one night before uh i'm
doing the stuff mutter there's a one
night and i've played it before three
times you and i played it before you
shot a special there
and we got the i always book it's not a
huge theater good theaters we made one
night hopefully sell that bad boy out
and the person that runs it uh responded
to my team goes
uh sorry brendan uh doesn't align with
our beliefs and is it woke enough yeah
what yeah
seriously yeah straight up straight up
discriminatory this is a
this is so important to keep in mind i
went do you know me like i'm not mister
i'm not far right i'm not far left i'm
not mr woke i'm not and this is true
no no specifics just right yeah his
alignment with certain people and his
on response to the woke movement we
talks about being there for the
marginalized they're not the woke is
there if the margins are not helping
them out if the marginalized they're
only you're only if you're a black woman
if you're a black person or a person of
course transgender
you're only you're only
you're only allowed to be part of their
movement if you align with the
ideology otherwise you're not you can't
be a black you can't be a black
conservative you also can't be caitlyn
jenner no hold on you gotta align with
all the correctness otherwise you're
voted off the eye so it's not about the
people it's about the ideology it's
always been that way so the the
democrats a lot like it's very
interesting because
this this black supreme court justice
was they were given the republicans a
lot of like hell for the questions they
were asking this black woman she's very
remember they did that to homeboy well
well not all years ago
clarence thomas but they also there was
a black woman who was a conservative who
was up for the california supreme court
uh and she was
completely lambasted and and basically
blocked and who led that charge joe
biden
so don't tell me that woke is about the
marginalized it they're about the people
as long as they are aligned with their
agenda you know you know
shop show this morning you know bryce
mitchell thug nasty bryce mitchell yeah
uh featherweight undefeated yeah he's i
think he's ranked number seven or nine
or something like that but he want you
know his management wants a top five
fight for him
but
me and him we're talking yesterday i
want to have him on uh food truck but he
lives on a farm in what arkansas channel
yeah
he lives on a farm there right so
he's like i'm a homebody man i really
don't travel so i have to sometimes i
will but we'll figure it out it was too
much i was like let's just do a zoom
call right for right now he does a zoom
cult he's clearly he's on a farm so the
service is not great you know keeps
freezing stuff but he's
behind him
like there's turkeys and talk about this
turkey put him with like pigeons and the
turkey killed the pigeons and i'm like
yeah no doubt dude but before we were
talking bring him up he's a blonde kid
right uh you see him dusty brown bunch
but savage yes but you'll know him
because he he was on fox news on other
outlets because he was talking about
vaccines that's the government and how
the government wants to control us
so yesterday he goes hey man uh he's
like
you know i've been following you for a
while i know you know what i represent
but you know we don't have to just talk
about fighting i said bro
again i'm not a journalist you want to
talk about the gun control which i know
he's big on you want to talk about gun
control whatever
bring it on brother like whatever you
want to do
now do i agree with everything that he's
saying no and some of it he's
misinformed i did try to inform him on
it because i think he did the aerial
show and there was like dude you're
spreading misinformation and whatever
and i think for him you know he's a
young man
and he comes from arkansas he comes from
the country and you know guns are
everything in freedom of speech and
covenant he has his philosophy on the
government how it's controlling us and
all that stuff which is fine um you know
he's talking about i was asking about
gun control because he's big on second
amendment and they're taking he he said
you know i do think
government is involved with these school
shootings that's why i press back away i
don't think the government's killing
fourth graders and then he goes no i
don't mean it like that
and he was saying that the government i
think is aware of him could do more to
stop them and they're just not because
it pat it helps them pass the gun laws
yeah i take that a lot from the
conspiracy guys that's all that's take
our ar-15s yeah yeah that's not response
i'm not gonna debate him on that but i
just told him and he was like like look
how long it took in that shooting texas
recently the fourth graders and he goes
and it was a transgender guy and in my
head i'm like well no no no so then once
he got finished saying his part i go i
get with like the misinformation i go
just so you know and i and it's true
like i fell into the same kind of weird
space because because you're hearing
this stuff well not only here because
social media there's no journalists like
you know what i'm saying like there's
more content
yeah there's no there's no sensibility
there's no sensor so anybody can say
anything so when that shooter was going
on they found pictures that looked just
like him uh a man in a dress and like oh
it's a transgender shooter right because
obviously then the left's not gonna run
with the narrative all that stuff right
and that came out and people were saying
to me that like oh this transgender shop
this girl was like holy [ __ ]
not that i gave it
it was here who did it
but that went viral on the internet the
actual transgender person
in that dress goes whoa this is me i
agree i look similar i did not show you
up to school please stop spraying the
room yeah but if you're bryce and he you
know he's on social media later he looks
at that but then if you don't look into
it further you're gonna think that so
it is
misinformation at the same time he's
also in a current culture where a
younger man who's getting it from social
media and there's no
regulatory
kind of commission to go no no that's
fake news or we can't confirm this don't
don't spread that so he was like oh it's
transgender well no and i said also with
the shooting how long it took
i'm with you that drove me nuts you know
i have a kid who's going into first
grade i have a two-year-old and i told
him i said they're they're in a cop in
this world who could stop me from
entering that school they have to shoot
me in the back like there's not a chance
he goes yeah brother that's right i go
but
i talked to a cop my father-in-law was
caught for 30 years when he talked to a
cop and i said this is what helps me get
perspective when you talk to a cop now
did they make mistakes one hundred
percent tell them a small town had no
clue how to deal with this shooting this
active shooter and there's certain
things they could have done to prevent
more less deaths but i said the reason
why he was in there so long
and he had us come back and you're like
i don't know if you like this or agree
with it but i said you got to realize it
went from active shooter to hostage
situation and then bryce goes you you
guys keep saying that but there's
gunshots ringing off of him killing
those kids that should go from a host
situation to him murdering kids they
should enter the building and he goes
when those cops sign up
as cops they say hey we're going to with
our lives we're going to defend these
kids and they did not do that and i said
fair point yeah but that's the fact i'm
really quiet about this stuff and here's
why because you don't i'm not a cop
i wasn't there i sure as [ __ ] know
nothing about a hostage situation or an
active student i'm not trained for that
i don't know all the little variables on
the ground
so
you know one thing talking to multiple
cops yeah he said it was not handled
correctly i'm sure now sure as far as
not rushing in from the bat that's
because they were under an impression of
the hostage situation
but then once
once the two cops shot and wounded
that's a good question yes no you're
right yeah okay so so two cops were shot
i mean you stopped going in no but but
it does mean that's part of the gig a
lot of them thought they
i i wasn't there so i i i i think
everybody's got these points of view on
this but here's my thing being that's
why i said to bryce i said
the reason why i'm such a fan of yours
whether i agree with your points or not
i do think so it's misinformation on all
accounts left right middle everybody
doesn't know what the [ __ ] happened only
people there know what happened and we
get the reports we're like oh it's easy
for us to come up with judgment when it
comes to bryce said the reason why i
like you and i root for you is because
you speak your truth most athletes are
told to shut up and dribble shut up and
fight but you double down and because
it's natural to you you're not doing it
to get clicks or like he's far from that
yeah i said the reason why i like you is
because you speak your truth and you
believe in it whether i agree with it
right or wrong it doesn't matter you're
doing what you think is right in your
heart and that's why i [ __ ] with you man
now what he said do i agree with all of
it no of course not but a lot of it i
can see how people come to that
conclusion but there are a lot of see
the [ __ ] problem with misinformation
is this
you got good people like this kid who is
simply getting the wrong information
and then getting passionate about it and
then
galvanizing a community or joining a
community and and adding his voice to
the mix okay got a break brennan hey
let's take a little break buddy because
you know what dude there's a big ufc
coming up this saturday yeah yeah it's a
big one man ufc 275 is finally here and
our friends at draftking sportsbook the
official sports betting partner the ufc
has a heavyweight offer this weekend all
right it's so much fun finding the kid
army you can get in on it cause i got my
picks all right i picked yuri chefchenko
and we lay all right now listen if
you're gonna bet on yuri if you do this
parley they boost your odds if you'll
find it it's the bren shop picks if you
bet on yuri we need it done the first
two rounds because we've done to get
done first two rounds this is a five
round fight the old vet glovertex air is
gonna do some work on this man get them
down grab one price the minimum in the
fourth or fifth so we need the first two
rounds out of our boy here yeah i think
you can get it done so it's yuri
shevchenko and wayleigh all right just
head to the app now under the ufc page
to check out my picks bet on it and ride
along with your thick friend here right
now all customers can place the same
game parlay for saturday's fight and if
it hits you double your winnings
download the draftking sportsbook app
now use promo code fighter new customers
can throw down five dollars on ufc 275
and get 150 in free bets instantly
that's code fighter this saturday at
draftking sportsbook the official
sportswearing partner of the ufc minimum
age and eligibility restrictions apply
see show notes for details
look man i'm losing my hair
and i could go to the dermatologist or i
could go to keeps and i could
anonymously get yeah but when you're
gonna do it daddy like we've been doing
keeper reads for a hot second two you
don't like this i swear to god i swear
to god i said to my girl i go i have to
call keeps my girl said you gotta call
keeps two out of three men will
experience
by the time they're 35 i have more than
50 million men in the u.s suffer from
male pattern baldness and
keeps has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors there are only
two fda approved medications that can
prevent hair loss keeps offers both uh i
take one of them and i have taken both
you got to do both dude keeps offering a
simple affordable stress-free way to
keep your hair all right it's a virtual
doctor meeting it's a real time the
medication is delivered straight to your
door every three months 24 7 care and
support it's low cost treatments are
just 10 a month is here worth ten
dollars a month yes come on man yeah it
does everything your hair needs
delivered straight to your door discreet
little patches
packaging shows up proven results
prevention is key dream has taken up to
four to six months i i can tell you i
waited too long i did wait what you're
here save more spend less don't be like
brian if you're ready to take action
prevent hair loss go to k-e-e-p-s dot
com fighter to receive your first month
of treatment for free that's keeps.com
fighter to get your first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com
when you have a young man whose heart's
in the right place but doesn't
necessarily have the exposure experience
or education
to speak on these things and i and i you
know
that's where that's the challenge
for everyone and the the more sinister
thing is that
it would since you can spread this false
information since you can say somebody
can just say hey this shooter was a
trans guy you can rally the troops
around them so when you say this kid was
a trans kid kid everybody goes ah see
these trans people were killing people
okay because i heard that too yeah now
if there's an election
and you have comes down to the wire
and you have a very sophisticated group
of people that can throw out
misinformation and bots or whatever and
they hit the population with a really
great story that's super seductive
three hours before they hit the polls
you're screwed you don't have time to
tell them it's [ __ ] and you can win
an election that way so so
everybody's like oh we should allow all
information okay yeah i understand that
until people are so good at [ __ ] with
information that they get somebody that
you totally disagree with elected in the
office and they do it over and over
again so now why to that point there
there should be
some sort of
oversight of information being put out
there because what you can also do well
that's where his rally is rally the the
troops the incels over a narrative of
racism or whatever or transgender or
black people and it's like whoa hold on
yeah where if you had someone to educate
on the opinion go sit down or get into
their group chat and go hold on dude
you're off on this you're off on this
you're off on this you're off on this
and then go oh
but because it's not in their narrative
then can spread this misinformation and
really capitalize on it and that's where
you get mass shootings so so here here's
where rallies and antifa and proud like
it gets dicey dude this this is this is
where i'm gonna take a little heat for
this but but it's important to say so
the mainstream media really dropped the
ball because it used to be that i never
agree with a lot of things that the
washington post new york times
you know places like this they come out
with articles that are very slanted and
i think that there's an agenda there but
the one thing about the new york times
washington post etc at least back when i
was coming up you knew that the
information was vetted it was really
vetted they [ __ ] up sometimes but for
the most part they have a very strong
vetting process why because the entire
business world like with the wall street
journal they were banking on yeah okay
so so but they lost their way they lost
well look when you when you float a
story about russian collusion b
yes money when you're floating a story
about russian collusion and a three-year
investigation to your investigation with
all that money finds a nothing burger
[ __ ] nothing
you got a problem man because because
now you've got people in power like
hillary clinton and on and uh uh pelosi
schiff and pelosi and all of them
constantly saying put putting this
narrative out and they knew
that there was no actual information the
problem is
remember they didn't start off like that
they start off where they earn the trust
of people so then what they say people
like well she's saying it has to be true
all you gotta do is raise a question but
now what happened where this russia
collusion all that and what did we find
out that biden's son was more involved
with the russians across sea
business than anybody else
but that doesn't get reported what
happened you see me hit the mic like
that yes you see that [ __ ] people lose
[ __ ] faith in media yeah and that's a
big problem because well the media
soldier sold their soul to the devil
with money because instead of reporting
stories
we need ratings now you can't you can't
turn on fox can't turn on cnn because
they both have these insane agendas one
hates this guy the other hates this
person so it's like i guess i can't
watch it i listen to fox and i'm like oh
boy here they go they're not giving
anybody the benefit of doubt it's all
like they want to kill us they want to
put us in concentration camps you know
it's like yeah it's like it's like this
my joke is like with uh with cnn they
can find racism and inequality that we
have ghost hunter can find a [ __ ]
ghost correct right and then fox
fox is like racism we gave him the vote
what are you talking about
it's like i i can finish their sentences
then you get political leaders something
that was really interesting about
trudeau
up in canada said said something great i
think it was uh jordan peterson said
handsome guy
handsome son of a [ __ ] damn it i know
him him and knew some handsome devil you
can finish newsome you can finish and
they're i'm that's not just picking on
the left but definitely you can with
gavin newsom and and justin trudeau
i can finish their sentences you know
why if there's a position global warming
gun control masks whatever it is
all they do is read from the handbook i
can tell you they don't have to be there
they should just have a talking head
that goes that that basically
says exactly
by word for word scripted what the far
left is going to hold to be true but the
right same right same way the right same
way like ted cruz like with the gun i'm
like i know what he's going to say or
abbott you're like i know what he's
saying that's that's called ideology
that's called that's not good you you
would but
who who out there is going to solve this
problem not the two of us bubba no like
no is it elon musk people are pushing
back i know but what what what outlet is
gonna go hey we realize there's a
problem we're gonna only give
facts from left right only facts here i
know who's doing that but look dude
we're in a debate right now we're
[ __ ] the biggest debate is
should they should they censor
information shh or should they not say
and we're and i'm i don't know you know
what i'm 55 i actually don't know the
[ __ ] answer
i don't know the answer is my same thing
with gun control how's it going
at what point do we go all right well
just leaving it the wild west ain't
working because there's a lot of incels
there's a lot of negativity in the way
it's affecting kids suicide this ain't
working yeah do you think it's gonna get
better by not doing anything
do you think or do you think it stays
the same that's a very important
question that you're asking and we
better answer it you can't run from the
questions okay and then so do you have
that on freedom of speech as far as gun
control are things getting better the
way we're doing it or is it getting
worse because the numbers are seeing way
worse well let me give you and then also
with the numbers now depending the way
you look at the stats
guns are the number one thing that kills
children now it used to be car wrecks
guns if you include 17 year olds now
more kids die by guns than anything else
let me give you suicide all that yeah i
want to give you some stats on that
because we're going to take heat so i
want to just and this is something from
i listen to a guy who's very informed on
this i think his name is charlie kirk
kirk
and it here's the interesting thing
about gun control that people should
know number one we're the only country
in the world that includes suicides okay
if you take suicides out of that
equation okay you just talk about that
yeah and so i think it was last year
let's take the stats for last year you
have roughly 8 000 gun deaths
80 of those gun deaths 80 percent
so of the 8 000
about 700 are actually um about 700 are
actually accidental discharges okay all
right about discharges okay they're
accidental discharges
so now you got about seven thousand of
those of that seven thousand of change
eighty percent of the deaths of the gun
deaths are inner city gang on gang
violence with handguns
that leaves about 2 000
homicides done which includes mass
shooters okay of the mass shooting about
i think it's three to four percent are
actually used they use a rifle okay so
it's very interesting to see these these
actual when you break these stats down
it's really interesting
of course it's a problem when fourth
graders get in child when you say 45 000
deaths
it's actually about 2 000 homicides and
obviously nobody wants this but but then
also
but also to say well let's take suicide
out well no that's a huge issue that's
killing a lot of people well so now
we're dealing with what we're dealing
with the illness thing and now and these
shooters that buffalo shooter and that
[ __ ] this kid they were showing signs
of major mental illness hold on the
parkland shooter made your size yeah but
the the rumor was alerted twice to this
kid for sure but the part the buffalo
shooter would be a case to me it would
be
monitoring freedom of speech and be
having this misinformation him being you
know compromised through a group so it's
not freedom of speech when you're making
direct freedom of speech you're making
direct threats but i'm sorry uncensoring
information yeah that's that's where
that
argument comes from that kid well the
kids showed up i believe at school and i
have to check this i think it was him
who showed up to school for a week in a
complete hazmat suit correct wouldn't
take it that's correct now the students
and the teachers like this kid is crazy
this kid something is very wrong with
this kid and they were all afraid of him
he would make really weird faces there
were signs
along the way that this kid was so
mentally ill he was going to do
something insane now
why is it
that a kid this
unhinged was able to buy [ __ ] uh two
ar-15s or whatever
on on his birthday now we gotta in the
ammo but then guns in general forget ar
just means armor light thank you guys
for educating me armor like uh armalite
which is a company that yes m4s and m60s
but also that that kid you know showed
signs on social media was able to find a
group
to to compromise
and make a mistake
well it's gonna be easier to find a
group online if you like eating poo you
can find your group on [ __ ] wine yeah
they found me forever oh they found me
on there yeah oh yeah i was like what
i'm not doing i don't want it in this
group huh crazy what'd you eat for
breakfast
hey man we've been a little dark
are we okay i don't think this is good
talk right i enjoy it but then again i'm
a political science major guys you know
2005 promote college whatever that voice
why don't you just [ __ ] why don't you
why don't you dj at a strip club and now
coming to the statement
he's old he's wrinkled but he's got a
great attitude and he's flexible for a
55 year old i know he looks weird and
his body's really wrinkly and old but
positive attitude he's got to do he
takes change ladies and gentlemen he's
the only stripper we have that takes
tokens that's right because he still
uses pay phones yeah heavy dick no guys
but even heavier ball
balls coming to the stage if you're
thinking of crypto or cash app forget
about it cash he's older this antique
this antique has been doing his lunges
his ass has still got it ladies and
gentlemen he's still got a bit of a
booty and hopefully invisalign gets a
rock hard gentlemen because he's wearing
them because he's worried about his
teeth out of all the things wrong in his
life when he talks to you he will be
spitting in your face by accident all
right this guy will work for free just
give him some attention and pet his leg
and this is all nude venue but he will
have his sandals on he's got a
leaking be wearing his toe flip-flops
ladies and gentlemen so he doesn't move
very well hey ladies if you're not wet
already he's going to have sandals
invisalign that's right and his hair is
leaving as we speak don't let him sit on
your lap because he's got a leaky behind
that's what happens when you're older
he's got a leaky mud whistle ladies and
gentlemen so he's wearing very thin
diapers he's only here at 8 30 p.m
because he's tired he won't be here for
the late show so get your money while he
can we're gonna get him hopped up on
coke and adderall his heart will
probably stop so get him while you can
two weeks only brian the kid rings
callum he fidgets he fidgets hard
and ladies are looking for conversation
boy there's none better he might not
look like much but he is a fun combo
politics check history gun control check
kovid jesus
[ __ ] he's got plenty of opinions that
aren't even his but they were given to
him by somebody on youtube like jordan
peterson if this guy can [ __ ] parrot
have you met him if you missed the
latest tech talk he will regurgitate it
in your ear and get all the facts wrong
but it'll be rock hard ladies rock hard
that's right he's the only 55 year old
who needs no
[ __ ] viagra why testosterone may be
pervert definitely
all right
boom boom room forget about it he'll do
it wherever
especially he's eating ass in alleys
ladies give it up he eats hats one night
openly and i
[Applause]
here he is ladies and gentlemen he works
for change throw those coins at his face
he bruises easily he can't assimilate
iron
he has two kids this is getting sad he's
got three kids he's oh that's right he's
three now so even better give him your
token which means he's gotta hustle for
20 more years years years
are you into hacky sack who hacky sacked
naked with his dick out wanna know what
life was like in 1985 he can tell you he
graduated high school before you were
born who in here went to new york
he loves talking about new york as well
give it up he's got a lot of new york
stories some of them might not be his
but he's so desperate to be in new york
and then he comes up with things mary
tell you this i bet you can't name a
celebrity that he won't say it's my
friend give it up for brian gallon about
me when i would like try to be tough and
i get i get angry and i and i go like
this my buddy hunter mata knows
everything about me i grew up all over
the world my mother is from brooklyn she
is sicilian and i go and so sometimes i
become sicilian and i go let me [ __ ]
tell you something right now that
[ __ ] i literally go i let me tell you
right now i'll [ __ ] i'll [ __ ] show
up that guy's [ __ ] play i'll punch
him right in the [ __ ] yeah i was so
angry yeah and and and hunter goes wow
because where brian isn't from they do
that stuff all the time
listen t-shirts okay i'm very particular
about my t-shirts me too dude some
teachers make me look skinny some
teachers make some guys look fat i want
t-shirts i don't like the boxy one i
need it fitted and i like it tightening
the cuts dude because daddy works too
hard on the gym not to show off this
baboon chest and the shoulders listen
you want buttery soft premium fabric oh
my god do i have another the colors
daddy's popping on the coaster because
simple's in right now so the logos
aren't in i know i'm wearing a lot of
logos right now but take it from me you
don't wear a lot of logos you want
simple nice jeans nice cuts they're made
to last though they're made to last
a quality dude they have tons of great
styles colors henley's long sleeves
there's some for everyone cuts is on
fire right now gq even labeling the only
shirt worth wearing that's crazy look
good feel good the moment you try one of
these shirts on you'll get it there's
none better refresh your wardrobe in
time for the summer with cuts see for
yourself white cuts is one of the fast
growing men's brands with over a million
shirts sold get 15 off your first order
by going to cutsclothing.com fighter
that's cuts c-u-t-s clothing.com fighter
[Laughter]
mark likes that one i also like doing
this stripper bit i was imagining it was
a gay club but for like guys in the
audience oh no and then and then you're
like ladies i'm like oh [ __ ] right it
would be like yeah well mark speaking of
[ __ ] body dump your instagram post
bring up mark's body on this instagram
is there a new one
it's [ __ ] i don't see it you know
here's what i do what a body i actually
a lot of people think like i'll get
accused of this you just post truly i
don't really
i give myself enough attention
i'll have a bunch of pics where i'm like
i took these over the course of a few
weeks i just want to get them out so i
did one of these go back all the way
back
treat yourself chin create yourself
today but okay there's multiple books on
i don't know
multiple picks on that one yeah there's
multiple videos that's not even the good
one
you go forward yeah look at this that's
a good body dude
here's my thing anybody hating on this
who would if i had that body though who
wasn't i'd do the podcasting my shirt
off who doesn't want that body
what that dick do though let me see more
he's got a dick too he's got a deep
voice
yeah he's got i like his i like his legs
look at that
look at that look at that basketball
experiment with editing this is just all
my natty as [ __ ]
i was going to say
did you set the phone up on the thing
and then you hustle back and take the
pic now if you think i'm embarrassed of
people walking by me in the 24 50
absolutely it's just my life i'm sorry
i've bitten that bullet i'm not gonna
play it off and pretend like i'm not
doing this hey hey can i actually the
liver king yeah he's natural as [ __ ]
right um i mean that's really my only
bone to pick with him is he says he's
not giving credit for everything else
correct he he seems to what does he look
like right now i don't bring him on the
guy
we're not hating him
right because i can i like to
compartmentalize i kind of like him no i
think he's great he's actually my i've
made a running joke
hey hey hey everybody in there stop but
he's so awesome he's the best he doesn't
give a [ __ ] he just he's never wearing
clothes ever he's always like a
character and that's what i admire he's
pulling it off he does have an amazing
you don't you don't get that you could
take all the stairs
and
cooked meat raw organs he's a family man
he's got a great it seems like he's got
a great dad he's got a great family
people like to hate on him because i
guess he's probably getting a little
help but so what there's a lot of work
there yes
he denies it which i guess like
i have empathy for that because ago
maybe someone you if you have it in your
head you can't admit that because of
your business sure because maybe it
looks just admitting you're doing
something illegal you know the thing is
though mark
i mean he
in my experience gun to the head would i
say he's on something probably i will
say though man there's some freaks out
there and i've been around them where
they just
had it it's tough i know i i agree with
you there's certain things like your
genetic uh framework you're like you're
lean no matter what like yeah and then
you put on muscle so yeah you do that
like i'm not that much bigger than i was
in high school naturally right it's like
maybe i'm 20 pounds but yeah this guy
obviously if we could find him as a
teenager he probably looked somewhat
like this ah the muscle bellies are
filling out a young liver king i don't
know if there's a lot of pictures of him
online i'm just saying like
the reason we look at bodybuilders and
go oh my god that's he looks like he's
on stairs he's pretty jacked right so
you don't have for example tits that big
like no he's already genetically
like most people will never develop a
chest like he has as a teenager
in their entire life no
um
i think i think he's awesome i think
he's like the american he's just i love
also he's just he's just what he
preaches is actually pretty dope like he
he gives you
bits of wisdom and like approaches to
life where i go outside of the eating
raw meat you don't have to do that
outside of saying is natural you don't
have to agree with that but his approach
to life
is legitimate
that's what i like but my thing is so if
people are hating on this guy for saying
he's that's disgusting but if uh people
are saying uh they're hating him for
being all natural
i don't you know i don't see social
media so is he on there constantly
saying all night
no people
about it and i like i just would be the
last like again i
talk about it openly if i didn't do that
i wouldn't appreciate people constantly
bombarding me with it because it takes
away all your hard work whatever yes he
might feel like he's in a position where
he can't talk about it openly and look
ronnie coleman is on jay leno [ __ ] 20
years ago talking about yeah i'm all
natural never in steroids there's a ti
it's it's a taboo for certain things and
you just can't do it you make it i would
say this i would say this
the guy has created a name for himself
by by being an outstanding thing to look
at he's just fun right he's he preaches
he [ __ ] eats from doing his thing
yeah he works out like a [ __ ] he
seems like he seems like a great family
man he's making money he's got money
he's saying it's okay to be a man too
yeah by being this caricature of like
but also but also how is what he's doing
any different yeah maybe he doesn't have
a subscription plan how's this any
different than some girl getting fake
ass and titties go on only fancy oh yeah
hate on that how many girls have uh fake
[ __ ] on their bodies
decides they're going to live their life
on their terms he's like i'm going to
wear just shorts yeah i'm going to be a
caveman people hate it and why do they
hate it because it's triggering because
they can't live that long yeah they're
afraid they're afraid to put it all on
the line like that i mean he's made a
[ __ ] living doing like just being a
[ __ ] raw food and
raw meat and i would imagine those
people hating on him i would be willing
to bet even their avatar is not the real
photo it's a they're even scared to put
that out there oh yeah let alone this
guy in [ __ ] gene shorts with raw
liver you know do you know what people
don't realize the more you hate and the
more you do that it just drives the
algorithm up and you make more money
yeah no he's he's divisive exactly and
so how did he go to a million followers
so quickly because he kind of appeared
out of nowhere i'm very fascinated by
him and i always think with people like
that you go take notes if you have this
instinct and i do i look at them and go
but you're not natural and i did a
segment on him and said look the only
thing i have an issue with this
it is i would consider it for me
unethical but i understand why he does
it and then you move past that and go
he's awesome yeah
yeah
but there's also you also don't know
you also have correct no evidence are
you willing to take it are you gonna
also donate every day for the rest of
your life like
prove it right i don't much care right
nobody you're right but also are you not
gonna go to a rock movie because he's
not all natural correct are you not
gonna go see superman or ben affleck
because they're not all natural i love
thinking about you you draw the line
where do you draw the line the other
things you don't give a [ __ ] about he's
entertaining
the rock is entertaining wwe is
entertaining how is liver king find out
how old he is i'm curious i'm guessing
he's 40 minutes 46 yeah that's right he
looks fantastic but it's also with with
even like this cancel there's no way
he's 44 44 there's no why can't it be 44
i could have sworn i heard him on some
sort of interview saying like at least
46 because he looks older
uh steroids he looks like a mid-40s
steroids guy to me
yes
like here i can imagine being 44 but not
now yeah
but i think it's awesome where does he
live we should get him on the podcast
yeah he'd be great but i also think it's
weird how people decide like what
they'll put up with as far as like this
cancel culture and who's canceled and
voted off island and i'll go through
people on podcasts or comedy shows where
they'll allow this guy but not this guy
or they'll subscribe to this guy's
podcast not this guy's pockets or the
what does support this guy not this guy
and i'll be like well you know this guy
was canceled off social media he was
guilty by social media
this guy
literally by a jury of 12 was convicted
of rape but you'll have him on and he
can do this and that's okay
yeah because why because time has gone
by so time
is your thing
i think like where do you draw the line
at i love inc because it's so crazy and
people just pointing that out to people
is going to upset them but most the
average person has an insane amount of
ethical inconsistencies oh always it's
really insane although this con like if
you could pull all their opinions at
once and just look for oh over here and
then 180 degrees opposite over here
and you're just not aware of it this is
it's really hard as a human being not to
be contradictory it's [ __ ] yeah
everybody has almost impossible
my thing is you know they'll be like oh
well you said this like yeah that fell
on monday but now it's a different
monday i feel different because i got
some perspective or someone's like facts
yeah someone to that point the
misinformation be like hey dude you're
off on this i'll click that it's a legit
source i'm like oh that makes sense i'm
open i'm not dying on that hill pretend
i know everything but maybe on monday i
didn't have all the facts i felt that
way this monday on the show i got facts
cool all good yep
yeah brian's back again he's got plantar
fasciitis so he's not going to be
dancing too much although he is wearing
a still hole he's just going to stand
there and jack it ladies that's right
not a lot of movement because he doesn't
want to get worn out he's the thinker
he's rodin's thinker that's right he's
just sitting there thinking ladies and
gentlemen i've been djing for a long
time but i bet my last dollar he's going
to tell his face is swollen from
drinking wine the night before it's too
much salt and drinks wine daddy ate uh
indian food yesterday
[ __ ] your pants oh well i took four
shits this morning yeah i took four
it's the it's the spices holy [ __ ] yeah
daddy stays away from that but daddy had
a little dustin pouriers by the way my
my uh my my youtube show best of drops
today with dustin poirier he's already
dropped thiago
avenue coming out it's coming out very
soon so we're it's it's rendering right
now and we're going to drop it back up
on my users you don't you know you don't
have a specific time it drops uh i don't
have a specific time i should though huh
okay i will i will it'll be dropping
very soon yeah that's right but uh i i
had a little dust and pouriers uh hot
sauce it's delicious let that ass hole
up um yeah my [ __ ] my [ __ ] this
morning was like
because i ate a little too much of it it
was so good i kept eating it yeah yeah
and then i deal with the pain yeah and
then do you get heartburn i don't ooh i
get bad heartburn i don't care i guess
such bad heartburn sometimes yeah
you know what i have wet food uh
really it's whiskey and not eating but
uh chin you know what uh i've had that
let's give a
go first old one yeah i'm just looking
at his youtube channel
jen you know what i had that you're
appreciating cat hates on me for this
but um uh benihanas you get delivered to
the crib and you get the hibachi it's
always great it's fantastic cat's hating
on it but it's fantastic dude i'm
telling you
honestly what is your angle of hatred
has changed the whole game you know yeah
you know
you know steve aoki's dad invented benny
hannah's oh that's right and he has a
benihanas in his backyard so is travis
barkley
hana is no okay i heard a bunch of guys
one time talking so a long time ago they
were all uh black belts and jiu jitsu
they were they were mma guys and they
were all talking about how jiu jitsu
gracie jiu jitsu sucks i was like listen
you [ __ ] dummies you guys you guys
train they were all mma guys and then
but they what they were was like we
don't do great we do our own jiu-jitsu
yeah [ __ ] what you wouldn't be
anywhere without that genius that the
gracies were that created jiu-jitsu i'm
sorry how's this related to hibachi oh
it's same same idea when people like
diss uh benihana's and they're like no i
like originally no dude the original
they they changed it no i'm telling you
you get it for delivery it comes in a
nice little package you can separate and
it comes with a sauce on the side
delivery yeah because i live close to
one so they it's like 20 minute wait
they [ __ ] bring it there dude i
finished uh stranger things season four
okay new new two new episodes one's a
hour and thirty the other is two hours
long drops july 1st dude are you a
stranger things fan uh no oh
no duh
oh it's
so good dude it's so well yeah and you
had a little benny i wanna i wanna start
with my night baby
stranger things benny i think was he was
a genius because he was the first person
one of the first people to to think of
he said i don't want the chairs too
comfortable
i want them after an hour to want to get
up because the chairs because i want to
turn over i want to turn the sure that's
mean but sure yeah but it was a great
business i want stools yeah i told that
time i told the story on rogan years ago
i went to betty hanna's and i remember
being at benihana's i think i was in
college or maybe high school i forget i
didn't have money but uh my group of
friends decided to go there i'm like
i've never been before right so we go
there and it's it's not cheap dude no
it's not cheap food so we're ordering my
head like [ __ ] man and i'm going through
it and the gentleman who was older next
to me realized i was like looking like
at my uh wallet and i was like going
through and like looking at the menu and
then he go he bounces and goes tommy do
whatever you want man
and i was like oh thanks man so i just
you know i didn't go extravagant i just
got whatever the normal chicken shrimp
whatever
then fast forward i don't know four or
five years ago i'm at betty hanna's and
there's a two young couple on a date and
they have a coupon like a groupon
and they're like and she goes babe can
we get drinks he's like all right well
he's added up i go hey i got it
and you can tell he's a young kid and
he's like no i'm good mango bubba
someone did this for me i'm just paying
it forward dude i got you tonight
literally do whatever you guys want now
he's different than me he went
he's different i got the bag of diamonds
i want to bring him different than me he
went very cool do you guys have wagyu
and what take seven of your strongest
long island drinks i mean the bill was
insane but they had fun yeah that's me
paying forward wait a second hey bro oh
i was like
hey hey i got the bills like like
all right to drive home yeah you know
they had golden wagon [ __ ] hey yeah
that's an amazing story yeah pretty
awesome though yeah [ __ ] what can you
do that's great yeah [ __ ] benny
honest man yeah benny i'm telling you
you you mean my girl or to go sunday
nights that's our thing anybody make a
restaurant work good luck oh restaurants
are nightmares and dude i looked at that
margins for how much i was like a really
expensive good restaurant than what they
make a night it's not as much as you
think man it's a lot of well the worst
businesses to go into are gyms and
restaurants
four years to just until you break even
you gotta plan on four years now that's
not during today's climate this you're
talking
about five years ago yeah with covet it
didn't and inflation people i'm sure
approached you about james oh my god
weekly
as far as going into gyms oh weekly oh
yeah weekly yeah yeah i we could no i
could open up my dm's and there's gym
the rock could own a gym and nobody's
the bianca's just coming to a gym
because you're there no no and you you
and also people think oh i'll get these
famous fighters at my gym you don't make
money off famous fighters you make money
off having a lot of students so like
that's why kids programs are huge huge
that's why the gracies like kenner and
heron make so much money smarter they
have so many people they've reversed the
grace university online during
pandemical of course but also their
children program you go you go to the
maths dude
every any given class 50 60 kids and
henry's teaching it you're not getting
some
lower level black belt no no hannah's
there or or eve or his wife or uh or
hiron's teaching or his wife's teaching
it you know what i'm saying like you're
getting legit coaching man yeah but it's
all in the kids program and then also
how many members you have dude i was i
was at yeah i already told you about the
story about top team how many yeah
russians yeah yeah
that's a different thing like yeah i was
talking about this on shop show but i
went on weird rant
if you're the ufc then
it's monday marketing day right you're
dana white's we're at a big round table
at the apec center and dana goes hey
let's call in
and you gotta look at the roster right
you have an incoming amount of talent
from russia
and dagestan they're unstoppable the
chance of people being they're not good
they just are unstoppable they're not
ensembles they're going to soldiers
we know it's going to take over we know
they're taking over okay cool so these
dag stains kevin russians are coming
what do you marketing wise now think
about it russia is in a war right now
with ukraine so being russian in america
ain't the coolest thing right so
do we sign more russians and try to
market these russians to american
fan base which we know is probably not
going to go great very hard or are we
are we saying
we're good in america this is what it is
we're crushing it let's start getting
international again the russian fighters
the chinese fighters you know
do you stop do you not sign as many
dagger standings in russian because you
know they're gonna take over it's just a
matter of time because think about the
business this is interesting right how
are you going to market it they don't
really speak english you know they
they're so they're so they're so they're
dry and all they do is win humble yeah
they're not the most exciting you know
so what do you do you know i'm saying
like if you're a marketing team how do
you market this to the american fan base
they're they're well now you can do one
of two things because also your business
model not now now you just got to fill
cards right now with espn deal you're
just filling whatever 46 cards every
year pay-per-view and the fight nights
so previous they're being sold and doing
the espn deal it was based off paper
that's why pay-per-view stars were a big
deal connor nate diaz nick diaz
anderson silva vitor belfort
jon jones the the guy they made their
not off pay-per-view
all those those people that i just
mentioned
are older they're you know conor has one
or two fights left nick nate have one
fight left mazdal you know not many left
you look at the the the pay-per-view
draws they're older man
so what are you marking i say what i
want
i bring it up because i think it's a
problem so my argument that they're not
forecasting my argument would be
joyce gracie who didn't speak english
very well or he did but he was brazilian
he spoke english but he was brazilian
anderson civil was brazilian so there
were a lot of there are a lot of
brazilians that hold the holy spirit
destroy this argument anderson silva was
a knockout artist
front kicked
people in the [ __ ] face you're
worried about you're worried about
insane wrestlers like khabib who are
shutting people down with that wrestling
now now
they're there
as a as a business we got to decide all
right how many do we want to sign
because if we sign 10 of these dagger
standings that are little khabibs or
everybody's going to have a chin strap
beard 10 of these russians
one through 10 is going to be russia one
through tends to be daggers do you think
so yes i know so you do you think that
they're that now you're not some
outliers in america
but but that's but that's like a russian
getting into the nfl market going we
need more russians brazilians and
americans breaking through that russian
curtain
isn't that what you maybe but
but my point is it's not going to be the
majority
maka jeff is going to be the champion
yeah
how long do you want to wait hello and
if they give him the title shot today
he's going to use
he's got to get through some monsters
sure sure and then what about the guys
behind him that are chomping at the bit
that are good enough to compete right
now do we sign all of them do you hold
off how do you market to the u.s fan
base
do you wait till the war is over it's
very tough isn't it weird it's very
tough because you're dealing with a
meritocracy it is an international sport
now now no problem with you get chinese
fighters who are who are you know the
china's now now you got the chinese
market
uh well that big money in the chinese
market right big money in the russia
russia market is big for huge money
but i'm saying as the american market
that would be like the nfl going over to
russia or china going look at these guys
and they're all black going they they're
they're good they're just like us in
russia no they're not transgender
they're nothing like this yeah but
they're going hey don't you want to
watch this sport and china russia no
we're good they don't look like us they
don't speak our language yeah they they
don't have it they don't mess with our
architects they haven't broken they're
starting to but they haven't quite
broken into the african market and
well i told to francis and ghana goes oh
i wish i could say i'm special if you go
there if you get off the heels if you
got off the plane right now and walk to
my camera village he goes sonic i'm not
huge nigeria there's all these guys on
tap talent just walking around they look
he goes i was born like this they're all
walking around he goes i decided to get
into fighting
because
the same thing because i have all my
group of friends all look like me dude
i'm like
what i go and then i told him on air
with mike tyson i go we need to go to
africa dude and we'll sign like 10 of
you oh yeah well dude and then just take
over well so well until the dag stains
go very cool hold our bear because there
you if you want to ship them to dagste
and russia to learn grappling i was
going to say because grappling is always
going to fighting's different you know
it's like it's like football like it
i think what would change the game is
you have all these russians okay
if the money was there you would start
getting you would start getting some of
the guys who are in the nba in the in
mlb talking 20-year plan here bubba i
know i'm talking next five years
these dag stains russians are focused on
fighting they're coming up in [ __ ]
they're coming up and changing it's very
hard it's their culture it's very hard
to deal with no we can't do no dude we
can't deal with it because they have
such they even their boxing they're so
fundamentally
sound and amazing
they're just so good i'm boxing i'll
still take latin america or america over
russia but yeah i don't know i i know
yeah i mean yeah mexicans um americans
but the russians like russians have got
some [ __ ] kills yeah
good luck being haney yeah yeah yeah
you're like being tyson fury if you're
russian or not he's beating russia he's
he's beating all the russians yeah yeah
yeah including the klitschkos oh yeah uh
yeah the there's there's
talking to thiago alva's about the
russians and he said
they're they're you it's impossible not
to love them because they come in
they're so humble they're so open to
learning
they're so hungry
i can't say for russia i don't know
russians i don't think some day
it's crazy same thing with russia the
dagger saying the the the discipline and
their approach like it's second to none
they've also been schooled in sport from
a very young age in combat sport brian
that's the point in combat wrestling so
here so here my son's athletic gif he's
gifted athletically i take him jesus
tonight he does very well but it's not
if he doesn't do well it's not like he's
not going to eat or it's his only way to
get out of the hood
i mean calabasas here's what i think
he's this other dagestan kid's coming up
he he's climbing the mountain with goats
dude he's four i have a i haven't have
any i'm stressed i have an answer for
you what man the the russians the
pakistanis and the russians might have
they might dominate for a while but like
anything else there they they have an
orthodoxy to their technique and people
would figure it out and have an antidote
to it you'd have people who would study
that and they'd go they'd go you got to
have your arm here as opposed to here
when they take you down because they're
going to try to be again you're talking
about a 20-year plan i'm talking making
money right next five years you'd learn
that in the next oh
oh
oh sweetie oh
old stripper but then again hey hold on
hold on hold on hold on let's go back to
it here he comes again ladies and
gentlemen this time he's got a liberty's
half asleep brian callum dagger stan um
yeah dude go strip in pakistan he grew
up
be nice to him don't kill him after this
he's got gray eyebrows that's right if
you look closely you can see gray coming
in the eyebrows he's disgusting he
smells like mushrooms because that's
what happens when you're old ukraine we
haven't smiled in a while but this
should bring a smile to your face it's
brian count in just sandals in a heavy
old day a heavy old dick an even heavier
bowl away
exits to the left that's right for those
of you who don't agree with this here's
my thing yeah so you're like oh it's the
amount of time he puts his hand here we
can
do you think these amazing coaches at
att
aka
jackson's jim oh name name of coach yeah
mark henry the union coach
do you not think these guys with
years of experience studied khabib to
the fullest extent mike brown
top five coaches amazing i love mike 100
well
himself he was cornering dust and
pouring when he fought khabib did you
not think
that they went hey when he when he grabs
the wrist here do
you think it's that easy to figure out
do you not think these these masterminds
these phil jacksons of mma didn't study
tape and go dude when he does this
because here's the thing you're seeing a
fraction a fraction of what khabib can
do tradition because he hasn't even
gotten to
plan c d e and f because a and b is
unstoppable
so so if you stop a and b
c d e and f are all in his back pockets
true he he's walked away undefeated
without getting to play in b bro
and you want to stop it brian he's
putting you on your back you know what
you are you're communist
look
that's what this boils down that's not
true
for me i love russia but you know you
know what you think about though
stresses me out what do you do
i think you just got to be like hey this
is it but if you're a purist you're
going that's the best that's right
whoever succeeds best of the best
because you can't say no no the problem
isn't if they were if they were wild
strikers it'd be different but if you
guys got guys are just closing the gap
and then taking you down and then
grinding you out that's not going to be
great for viewership that's a problem
but again if you can't stop it and that
guy is that good at like allah khabib
like a makachev who also but much of the
stress a lot of these guys are stopped
though a lot of russians get their ass
kicked peter young got beat by al
jermaine sterling's fair and square al
james outreach oh peter yan doesn't come
from the background of khabib or
makachev that wrestling grinding break
mentally break you no he's not from
there yeah
yeah so you're saying you think it's a
matter of time before the dagestanis the
russian wrestlers [ __ ] greco players
are going to be dominant
and and they're also studying striking i
mean you're going to have
i saw russians said
who i don't even know who they were they
were like this guy like six foot six
hitting the bag and i was like oh my
[ __ ] god like some of these guys
right this i'm not saying this story
just for this bit dude this
three weeks this is three weeks ago
my son's class new kid comes in he's in
jim shorts and t-shirt
uh how old is he
you know he's nine jesus christ it's the
biggest nine-year-old i've ever seen
thin but wiry strong yeah and i'm
talking to the coach i go he's doing his
parents problem and they're from russia
just came from russia well that's cool i
go does he i'm watching his footwork i
know jesus where is he from this russia
dude and what's his background is karate
i guess he's a black belt in karate oh
it hasn't grappled he's never grappled
before how interesting
he he shows up late so they just have
them you'll love the story they have
them just enter the the grappling
starting on feet he's a big kid for nine
now he's going it's 11 year old he's
been there
the longest the kid whatever kid belt it
is he's [ __ ] hoist gracie of the kids
class he dominates everybody
they put him with him because you can
tell the kid's really athletic
this i'm not even trying to be funny
here dude
i see the way the kids when i go this
kid's a problem he's like going in out
very machida style but tall russian kid
and his parents dad's in a suit on the
phone the whole time bluetooth i'm like
that's strange don't do that and then
the mom just glued in no facial
expressions and i'm like no emotion
let's kick and in my head excuse me bro
but i go he's going with the older kid
who can handle it the kids rolled with
everyone he competes you'll be all right
kids going in and out the the
experienced kid who's 11 goes to take
him down
the rush kid
who
never been a jitsu doesn't know the
rules
i swear on my life
elbow everyone's whoa
jesus
the [ __ ] and i go holy [ __ ] and the
coach goes whoa whoa buddy buddy there's
no hitting in jiu jitsu it's grappling
there's no no open fist no elbow none of
that and he goes oh sorry
and then and i look over dad's like this
i go oh well the parents
don't give a [ __ ] at all
so they go all right uh go with this kid
older kid
the higher belt you know he was going
with 11 year old beginning with 13 year
old ah this kid's bigger he'll handle
him thank god
he takes him down right away he gets the
russian down frowned upon his family i'm
sure you got beat when you got home he
[ __ ] takes him down single leg kid's
on his back
oh no oh no they go whoa buddy buddy
they're breaking up and their coaches
look right god who else can we [ __ ]
give this is a kid's a problem he'll get
tired
no absolutely not no they take the kid
off they're talking them where's to
y'all y'all dude what are we doing here
you can [ __ ] get a little fedor here
for [ __ ] sake
dude so it gets done and i'm like you
know i'm like no other parents really
know what's going on like jesus i'm like
you know this kid's a problem with my
head i'm like dude if you can't channel
this [ __ ] yeah oh he'll be undefeated so
i go up to the mom i go how does he she
goes broken is he's nine i go nine jesus
christ because he came from uh clearly
some background she goes uh
taekwondo oh cool man cool and the dad i
go bro your son i mean obviously huge
liability but if you could channel this
and teach him how
unstoppable like kids are gonna take
over the [ __ ] world the dad goes
walks out the door doesn't say anything
just walks out the door never seen that
russian kid again
yeah really no i think he's uh he got a
ak-47 shooting ukrainians right now yeah
i don't know
yeah i think he went back to russia to
fight the war i don't i'm telling you
man this kid was a pro i don't mean like
i'm as a nine-year-old jesus christ
cried elbows to the side of the head to
an 11 year old oh my god
it's so [ __ ] crazy man some of those
kids are just like he was someone's
getting hurt he's running to walls
[ __ ]
bumping into kids so so so chin bring up
eizer by jean for a sec and and i want
to see the countries that border izer by
sean
spelling bee champion county 2001 sorry
guys it's okay
eizer by jean
there it is okay now bring up the map
now let me see what is bordering ice or
by sean if you don't mind well there's
armenia
armenia um georgia let's find dagestan
where's dagestan there there's there's
turkmenistan uzbekistan
north kazakhstan to the northeast of it
i would assume
yep
tehran so azerbaijan is part of that
entire area where they all wrestle and
fight iran amazing wrestling
uh and lift weights a lot of olympic
waves just all really
so my buddy is was there with his son
his son is 13 with cauliflower ears
because his son
wrestled in azerbaijan for three years i
didn't draw him out yeah blue yep
sunward and this and and blue's a tough
[ __ ] dude yeah and blue said he
called me and he goes dude
these kids are 12 11 12 and 13 they
they're all training in basements and
stuff you got world champions everywhere
and olympic guys and everything he goes
when they brought out they were all it's
just wrestling and then sometimes they
would bring out gloves
and [ __ ] head here and all the kids
are like
yeah and they would [ __ ] just go they
just just crack
black eyes [ __ ] punched in the face
knocked down
that's what we're dealing with that that
that aggression that level of aggression
was just like and they're also taught to
not be scared because i think of like
the bullying thing about it it's like go
bully a russian saying don't ever hit
don't ever do this like
you're scared of being punched in the
face until it happens yeah you know
they're like oh that didn't end my life
yeah you know but what do you know and
they also they're trying to bully a
russian let me know how it goes for you
especially that nine-year-old little
fedor they brought in yeah this story
long boring or no no it was great what
are you talking about it was a problem
that's [ __ ] i pray every day when i
pull up the school time praying that
kid's not there oh my god did you ever
have that when you were training praying
that somebody didn't show up because you
had to spar some [ __ ] money i would
never pray but i would be like if that
certain guys showed up that you know
gave you fritz like [ __ ]
and then what's what's interesting about
fighting is
because in other parts of life if you
know somebody's a problem or they give
me problems you can be like i'm just not
going to deal with that you can navigate
but in fighting you got to go towards
what you know you're scared of because
that's how you can get better so you'd
your coach usually like hey you and him
you and him are you know you're like
dude just like there's this kid uh sean
sims who gave us all problems he's long
ranging
black belt uh under henzo great just a
[ __ ] problem we all hated going with
him man he was like oh god and he'd just
[ __ ] you up there's certain guys just
like [ __ ] i don't want you against this
guy yeah the the when i would just just
me remember i was boxing a lot and and
i'd get a text from wayne mcculloch and
he'd go you're sparring today and i
would be like like my i'd be like i just
get so nervous because i knew i was
going to get hit i'd be like because you
didn't do it like i wasn't even fighting
for a job it was like a schedule you
know like tuesday thursday or spa
then you would get in there like you'd
see the guy getting ready like god
if i can get him early you know it's
like but you can't
go away from that you gotta it's not in
your natural to run towards what gives
you the most problems but i think in
life if you approach that where all
right i i'm not good at this i struggle
at this i'm gonna attack this you got
good at being really uncomfortable
yeah yeah yeah i think i think being
uncomfortable that's being comfortable
please learn about life that's why
sports are great agree 100 but it's also
like as a comic like i was talking this
comic the other night
we were talking about tony rock who to
me i'll put up against anybody doing it
right now johnny's great i'll put tony
up against anybody pound for pound joke
writing crowd work it pout monster yep
it's just a matter of time for
the people realize what he is and he's
not chris rock's brother yeah i i i i'm
not saying anything out of turner
right now if you've got anything if you
have to buy a ticket he's probably he's
better than his brother right now i
would be want to put up tony rock's best
bit against chris rock's bit of all time
and it there's gonna be a debate there
he's that [ __ ] good yeah now he's
writing for tv shows and all this stuff
in a long time great guy never stop
doing it he's a true comic but uh this
comic who opens up for him on the road
was saying he goes yeah by watching him
you know he's really good at joke
writing his premises is really good and
he needed to get better at crowd work so
what he did is he dedicated which he
didn't want he was nervous before he'd
dedicate the first 10 minutes or just do
crowd work and then you know that's
years ago over a five-year period now
his crowd worked as some of the best you
ever see he mixes the crowd working with
his bits so it's like as comics it's
like you got to do what's going to make
you uncomfortable because you run the
set every night or you can try new [ __ ]
out you might say you're going to fail
some but that's the only way to sharpen
the blade 100 and
for me i get that from fighting it's
like there's certain guys you're like
[ __ ] dude i want to do that but all
right that's going to make me better
because i know if i can do it in the tr
in the training room then when it counts
i'm going to have those assets and have
those tools of being uncomfortable i
watch sometimes these d1 football
players like this guy from oklahoma
state running back or he's a
linebacker or something and i was
watching him he'd be there and then the
guy would run and they'd have to hit
each other and you'd have to keep them
like blocking and stuff and then tackle
the running so [ __ ] shove them so
aggressive dude it's so it's it's a and
it's constant competition constant and
if you and you're dealing with another
guy who's just as strong and as hungry
and as athletic and you're always in
combat with each other
that's what it is like as cu like
from the starter to the second third
string it was it wasn't that big of a
difference everyone was pretty [ __ ]
good man especially university of
colorado like we were stacked when i
played there so really it was like the
guy who he does well under pressure
knows the game plan you know what i'm
saying so it's like also when you talk
about the details details yep the
details the dedication then also when
you talk about that competition
like if you were going through training
camp unless it was like a big time like
all-american or you know all big 12 guy
if that starter had a bad week of
practice and that second string is bond
they're gonna put that second string so
when you're doing okay it works
ah pros there's money involved so it's a
little different but if you're doing an
oklahoma drill or you're doing you know
these these hitting drills and you're
taking it off another guy's doing well
you probably lose your job man so it's
like
it's this never-ending
anxiety man that you always got to put
on you know in in wrestling the only
taste i had was in high school you'd
have wrestle offs and whoever
got to was starting that that was heavy
pressure dude you did like imagine high
school now imagine that's a high school
wrestler imagine that that was
everything to me yeah imagine a division
one now and you want to be a pro so this
is like your grad your this is like your
medical school to be a doctor yeah but
also it's like so that wrestle off you
rush off prove your better it's over
yeah in division one it's like if i was
going against trying to play starting h
back or fullback
that competition started at winter
condition at 5 30 in the morning so i
made sure i beat that guy and the guy
behind him all through winter
conditioning in the spring ball into
summer camp conditioning into fall camp
into the season in the season no days
off no it never ends no breaks
competitive 24 7.
and you can never shut it off ever
it's exhausting dude it's great no
wonder your bones are so [ __ ] heavy
most people fail to realize you stay
injury free which is insane
you do have uh
you do have i'm russian yeah you're
russian and that's my point yeah
this entire podcast i'm
i [ __ ] 40 russian you come from
dagestan dude i'm not hairy enough too
smooth for them they beat me with rocks
yeah i don't know how it worked out
there i've never been out there
me neither but when dude that's one part
that i just i don't know i don't know
the politics on the lay of the land like
if someone's okay with people
pay this much to do stand up in russia
they're what's called turkmen people
their language is very it's like turkey
had a huge the ottoman empire had a huge
influence on that area oh yeah so they
i'm in the empire state because they
came in and they just basically took
over that land so how about i was ed and
well not educated i was giving you some
bullet points on the old bay of pigs
thank you sir thank you for reading
that's what i spent saturday morning
doing [ __ ] if i know i have the
morning for and i wake up before my kids
i'll take one thing like bay of pigs
because i'm super into the jfk stuff
and then you know with the hoover stuff
and dwight eisenhower all that and then
i'll go down a rabbit hole and then so
saturday morning is just the bay of pigs
because people always reference it like
oh that's why jfk got assassin and i was
like
what actually is the bay of pigs you
know what i'm saying like there's all
these conspiracy theories what in
history happened then you look at the
bay of pages like oh that was a royal
[ __ ] up by the scene it's important
yeah yeah huge huge [ __ ] up you know i'm
reading jeff gave me many mistakes there
oh yes he did yeah and so then why
really
really military the uh jfk
well that's another that might be why he
was assassinated and also you have nixon
on tape on record going you know we
don't with the jfk the bay of pigs
things which i don't want to get into
and then you have the head of cia
helping them out and then water yep and
then watergate happen it's fascinating
yeah it is
um i'm reading i'm rereading the old
testament
uh you know the the the bible the king
james bible hey hold on sir yeah you're
reading the only book that matters i'm
right i'm reading the only book there's
the new testament the old testament i'm
reading where it started and that's the
old testament i'm reading the book that
jesus christ read that jesus christ
followed he was a first century jew they
called him the rabbi so jesus was
immersed in what's called the old
testament sure now let's talk about how
many people actually contributed to that
old testament well a lot how many how
many people's philosophies and input are
into that well here's the thing when
people talk about housing when people
think about religion in the book of
numbers chapter 31 forgot about this
when yeah after john 3 16 after moses
goes hey i'm going to get you guys out
of egypt and then i'm going to part the
red sea and they're like we're leading
us to the promised land problem was he
took him into the wilderness and they
were like um we're dying of [ __ ]
thirst and there's no food and
mosquitoes and god goes hey these
israelites are complaining you don't
like that how about i ran a [ __ ]
plague on you mm-hmm and then in [ __ ]
uh numbers chapter 31 uh they went in
you'd be thrown out
they killed all the men oh yeah they
killed all you thank you they killed all
the men they killed all the men in this
war they had i think with the uh with
the people of moab or something they
kill all them uh all the moabites or the
hitotites or whatever they were
and then they take the women and the
little ones for themselves and then god
savages god said to moses hey
uh
how come you're taking the women that
have lane with another man yeah don't
remember what happened last time if you
guys broke out in a plague i.e syphilis
so go ahead and kill this is from god in
the old testament
go ahead and kill
all the women that have been with a man
and all the little ones who are male and
just keep the girls that haven't been
soiled yet
dummy
and they were punished for not doing
that in the first place now let me ask
you this
now when most said god talk to him do we
know this is
facts or
sir like who talked to whoever that god
was wasn't
how about this moses
moses myself who did everything for god
he said just go to the go to the rock
and water will come out and it didn't
come out and moses tapped it twice and
god goes didn't have faith in me so
guess what i'm not doing it now you
don't get to see the promised land
because remember the jews wanted the
desert for 40 years oh is god my wife
israelites wanted the desert for 40
years because they didn't have enough
faith and they said you guys are never
gonna see the problems man you guys
didn't believe in me even though you're
starving in your [ __ ] dying of thirst
your kids are going to do that uh so
[ __ ] off and even moses
says [ __ ] off in there basically moses's
brother moses brother didn't have a lot
of faith there was a there was a
situation where he was like he didn't
god didn't like his attitude yeah sure
and he so moses so god said to moses
take your brother and his son to the top
of this mountain and push him off take
all his clothes off take them all off
and give him to his son
and leave your brother up there and his
brother
died up there and then they mourned him
for 30 years you got to read the old
testament i forgot about all the [ __ ]
dude dude heartbreak bro heartbeat bro
it's like savage when people make a hard
pass though yeah but people make fun of
the quran but you got to make fun of all
the manuscripts if you're going to do
that because the old the people of the
old
days were not very nice now b why are
you reading this
uh i like to read all the old
manuscripts and then come back to the
new one because everything is built on
so the bible is the old testament the
new testament
is basically had such an influence in
western culture and in our culture that
it's either a rebuttal to it or it's an
evidence it's an affirmation the jews
follow the new testament the jews
followed the old testament old testament
the torah the first five books now that
now they would say that came first so
they're right and then the new testament
is what christians the new testament was
was was essentially a guy named a rabbi
named jesus christ comes along about a
thousand years later i think and he goes
guys there's
after the old testament yeah there's any
rules in this book if you want to spread
god's word you can't have like you can't
have all the way we dress and you can't
touch other you know people who are not
jews and you can't be so clannish let's
just invite everybody that's right you
know yeah okay keep going i like keep
going
to keep kosher we don't have to do all
these things keep going i like that i
like keep going everything okay eggs
okay this sounds understandable even
though even though the old testament a
lot of that was about science but anyway
okay keep going and so and so uh the
jews and the romans were like this guy's
a rabble rouser and also he's a heretic
meaning you're speaking against god
you're also saying you're the son of god
you can't have that yeah you can't say
that you're saying you're the messiah
basically
i'm in some in between right now and uh
and then they
crucified him and that's how they
torture people back then oh yeah
is the followers of christ
even though paul who was a rabbi didn't
meet christ but he fell off his ass his
name was saul and on the road to
damascus he was blinded by the light he
saw jesus he said why are you
persecuting christians and and he had a
revelation and he became the biggest he
wrote he established all the churches
everywhere including in turkey and
places and he wrote a lot of letters to
the churches about how to worship christ
and that's what's in the that's a lot of
that's what's in the new testament he's
like bruce lee of martial arts and the
new testament was written by men who
about 30 years later and between 30 and
100 years later are people who didn't
meet christ and some who did meet christ
his apostles and they talked about his
word they're interesting yeah and that's
that's the new testament but the radical
idea of the new testament was this love
your enemy turn the other cheek
that was a pretty radical thing in roman
unless it's read it yeah well
that would be because i've tried that
that's a very hard thing to do i'd like
to talk to somebody about it yeah that's
a that's a hard thing to turn your cheek
when you're constantly
getting right but i know you're a bad
guy because you're a comic
oh yeah yeah because you're a pro
athlete now a comic yeah i guess you're
the you are the worst person in the
world
you're the guy everybody should hate so
much because you are trying your best i
guess i guess they think you're arrogant
or something if we could just take out
brendan
yeah
public enemy number one is
his brandon shop because he's just a
dick
it's so weird we just get together
yeah so reading the bible huh
yeah yeah and i'll reread that that's
gonna take a hot second for daddy to
finish
it's a it's a tough does anything
resonate with you as you're reading the
what's that does anything resonate with
you
uh yes what resonates me about with me
about the old testament is how
how bad it makes look how bad it makes
god look and how bad it makes the
israelites look and it still was never
edited it was never they never they the
israelites the people that wrote the old
testament
wrote it
and it it's it's not the israelites are
not the people you'd want to be around
they they were they were pretty
genocidal in a lot of their wars but
they never changed it so they read the
bible consistencies
not all the way through well what's
fascinating about it is that we still
talk about it no extended family is
catholic but i've always just felt
creeped out by the catholic church to be
honest like like being
never but i would i want to revisit it
as an adult to go like what resonates
the old testament is fascinating what
resonates with me is they need new old
customers for dummies
well there is that there is yeah the the
old so so so so so the old testament the
fascinating thing is the first humans to
be born from adam and eve were cain and
abel yeah cain and abel are the first
people on earth right
what's the first thing that the two
people do cain kills his own brother
he [ __ ] kills his brother i'm
thinking of adam and eve and that's how
many starts adam and eve were in the
garden of eden they're the first man and
woman right but cain and abel were the
first man on me they were the offspring
they were the offspring of adam
okay so adam and eve were the first they
were the first woman yeah and then they
had sex they they
they well didn't one of them eat the
others rib no hold on army hammers all
hold my dna
adam was put in a deep sleep and eve was
fashioned
from adam's rib
so and now now now he was unfashioned
she was she was made god made eve out of
adam's rib now
the one thing god said is you guys can
do whatever the [ __ ] you want in the
garden
do not eat from the tree of knowledge
don't eat from the tree of knowledge
now
even in the garden of eden even in the
garden of eden that god made a paradise
you still can't keep what out a [ __ ]
snake yeah
there's always danger even for the first
people there's always [ __ ] danger in
them they're hills
in that [ __ ] tree but who said the
who told adam and eve they couldn't god
yes
god said to adam
not even the eve he said to adam do not
eat from that father do we know for sure
that he told her those im that
information huh do we know if she for
sure had those facts before she ate that
well the the devil the satan the serpent
the serpent said to eve
don't you want hold on the snake talk
yes don't you want knowledge on in what
and what language did the snake talk
probably okay i wasn't there okay i
haven't seen the daddy's in the snake's
talking in the group
hey hey don't you want to be a god too
why are you giving it up to just eat
take a bite and you will get knowledge
and she went
and that was one thing yeah and then eve
i mean adam is like hey what are you
guys doing and she was like
just apple's delicious like no i don't
think we can he goes hey
he he's nothing's going to happen we
will get knowledge dude
and he went he took a bite and then
god said
where are you adam and adam said i'm
hiding
and god said why are you hiding and adam
said because i'm naked and ashamed
and god said
who taught you to be ashamed of being
naked
have you eaten from the tree of
knowledge and you know what adam said no
it was the woman
it wasn't me it was a woman she told me
to and he said yeah well guess what
she's always gonna have pain especially
when she brings children in the world
and she'll have to suffer childbirth and
the death of her children and you you
piece of [ __ ] you will always be a
position and he said and then he said to
he said to the snake he said you'll
always crawl on your belly in the dust
and you will always have end enmity
man will be your enemy i will always put
a distance between you two you're always
gonna live in your mom's and that was
called paradise lost that milton wrote
and then adam and then kane and abel
come along and kane just hated abel you
know why right abel was just can you
shut your mouth on the bible first i
know i know okay
i mean i'm into it i'm just thinking
what are the underlying things i think
you did a really good job of bringing
that out of going what is this story
really about well because it's like
[ __ ] like if you're really nice like
abel was a great guy and cain was like
jealous yeah and killed him and then god
put a mark on him and and and cain had
to walk around with a mark on his head
and he goes to god my pain is too much
to bear and god goes cool
uh if anybody kills this [ __ ] guy if
anybody kills it you'll get you'll get
punished seven-fold so let him deal with
the people yeah so nobody gets to kill
him even because they hear him out of
his misery walk the earth with your mark
[ __ ] oh wow
god was mean dude oh god remember that
jim gaffin bit about the apple he goes
would you been tempted by an apple i
would have been like cover and caramel
come back to me
i put some chocolate on that [ __ ]
i don't know why i'm drawn to these
stories but
it is interesting well
it's still around i think it's still
around
yeah but the the other thing is is uh
you know with religion it's also the way
it's being delivered like when i was a
kid you know the priest or pastor where
the hell out church i was in
you know the way he's delivering so
boring it's kind of like when you're a
kid you're you're a history teacher like
right now i think i'm like dude you
could have made that so much fun i've
been into it yeah let me teach it
catholic church is boring so boring it's
they they too they need a remix i need
to remix that [ __ ] i could some music i
couldn't take it i would go to church
but there's a way there's a way they can
deliver it where kids would be more into
100 yeah tell the [ __ ] stories let me
tell the story everything is stories i
don't know if you're the guy for the gig
i'd be like i'd play the devil like oh
he's naked and then like hey dude you're
55 you can't have your [ __ ] out in front
of the kid
bro i'm doing what the book says
who's the chick with big tits
well that would be eve isn't
dude eve didn't have fake tits in a blog
putting on [ __ ] you don't know you
don't know
you don't know who's god who plays god
you are mark prime mark with his voice
no chin has no
this mark has a long hair yeah jesus
gray hair you know i got to get really
judgy though
oh
oh
oh you ate the apple that's interesting
because i said specifically not to
guess who pulled landscape duty [ __ ]
you know
guess whose back's gonna hurt now all
right jim what do you got getting me out
of this bible time let's go
chin's disgusting i'm not disgusted at
all so our first kernel
yeah this is gonna disgust you if you
haven't been discussing [ __ ] dude
um why don't i always send this to you
and then i can't find it myself okay so
somebody actually said this fan of yours
brendan sent this to me i thought it was
so good i had to bring it up on the show
a red robin restaurant in clackamas
served a disgusting salad dressing to a
man who expressed his ire that employees
racially discriminated against his
family a new lawsuit claimed so
basically this guy
went to red robin and complained that
his family was being
um
like discriminated yeah like they tried
to break up his group of eight he saw
other people were getting seated
together so he kind of points that out
and then it's also red robin bro there's
no great seating also seating
he said somebody came in my salad he
basically said somebody uh he found jizz
in his salad under the he he took
pictures of it he threw up he was
skeptical if that's true how does he
know someone nutted in a salad
because he ate it
i got it i gotta taste skeptical hip-hop
was human genetic material all right so
so if it's not his then we he's holding
okay that'd make me feel yeah that's how
many hinges on it's like did you jerk
off in your own salad to get yours i
would [ __ ] oh but can't they run i mean
i don't know how deep they want to go
with the story can they run the dna test
hey listen can you stop this cold case
murder trial and check this
semen for this guy because someone
jacked off in his cajun clucks and fries
they'll find it so when you get to the
bottom of this
can someone goes through his unlimited
[ __ ] fries at red robin and go away
from this murder case they gotta taste
them and work them in the restaurant
they're gonna go to maury povich and
read it out like you are not the jizzer
nut in your [ __ ] i'm sure we've all
had someone nut in our [ __ ] that yeah
at least spit
but i mean it is so if that's what did
you say
where where what where was it which is
outside portland
dude i'm in portland this thursday
friday saturday nobody jizz no one jizz
well i don't eat the food there i guess
no one jizz on my voodoo donut yeah
cause i will know it's not ice we're
gonna be watching you yeah hey no that
one's the one don't get the one from the
back
no i'm i'm gonna get like this in the
display i get the i only get the
chocolate glaze i'll know if you're
nutted on my chocolate
all right next let's see here
okay oh i think this is a good one
paramount sued over film rights uh so
this is an interesting story actually
that kind of brings up a philosophical
question
regarding entertainment and rights
so the guy who wrote the article that
the original top gun was based on in the
80s had an agreement that they could
license his material for the movie or
any sequels for 35 years that ran out
like in the middle of when you would
think like january 2020 let's say they
give a specific date here okay
they released it afterwards so he's
saying no no you guys had to have
released it within this time frame or
pay me more money and you would assume
because they released in 2022 that maybe
they
finished photography or post production
or something what's going to be their
rebuttal otherwise you know and what
does it even mean to say i have the
rights can you release that
you know within do you have to release
the movie publicly oh and then yeah
paramount's probably saying hey in the
details the movie didn't get released
till after the fact but his argument in
the court of law is hold up you wrote
this script before and had
and you're in production before the deal
was up and you dna is uh an israeli name
it's interesting yeah it's good
interesting oh i'm i'm sure
paramount okay are bad here's 10 mil
right because we've made how much money
i think i really the guy it's just his
family because maybe he passed away yeah
the family alleges the part two which
the insistence oh yeah and you remember
i was asking like that like in china and
russia how are they gonna figure out
like what are they because they don't
let like american propaganda fly there
yeah no pun intended but they just don't
let it happen there
china didn't release the movie yeah
because he had a
patch of taiwan i think on his jacket or
something more than that i'm sure yeah
but yeah it's like okay dude yes well
he's still blowing up though
sucks my [ __ ] or something on his you
can't have that frowned upon she's like
what what
has a lot of problems exactly right yeah
and then johnny yeah you know i had we
had to do a little follow-up because we
watched that
trial the verdict live tell you what i
wouldn't want to get in a headbutt
contest with his buddy on the left
oh jesus he does have a gigantic head is
that who is that that looks like uh
paltrow but it's not it's definitely not
gwyneth paltrow yeah he's he's amber
heard's mom johnny depp is
banging amber hurts mom now
johnny depp broke the bank on indian
food while overseas spending the night
with his closest friends
so cool yeah he's dressed though i think
it's awesome love it he's still a little
too deep in jack sparrow huh i love the
way he dresses me too i do i do the same
here's the other thing 60 grand at one
dinner there's not a restaurant in the
world in america you go to drop 60 grand
yeah how many people are there that's
how you go broke fifty
oh twenty
it's like even that do the average of
that that's three thousand dollars a
person
oh why all right because johnny likes
wine you spend 120 grand a month on wine
so he probably like high in wine so i
bet
everybody's got a thousand dollar bottle
you know
there's bottles of bee there's about
probably 20 grand there's some bottles
india yeah easy
he said no that's in britain
oh
he went to india
[ __ ] in your pants london has some of
the best indian lebanese food i mean
london and i'm sure maybe if it's a nice
if they have a nice wine like
he's dropping thousands of people they
do i guarantee that yeah
yeah
you eat that high-end indian food forget
it it's on another level yeah i don't
care who's making it you're [ __ ]
your pants isn't it that's so good on a
related note too just as far as spending
money this isn't the current event i'm
gonna bring up but
she i guess was renting at twenty
thousand dollar house during the quarter
airbnb was yeah which is always funny
because i always think if you're in this
position where you're like i can't
afford to pay the thing and i haven't
paid the money yet knows
was the ten thousand dollar airbnb not
enough yeah a month or so i don't think
she's great with money yeah you need
privacy gofundme shuts down our 1
million dollar fundraiser so people are
trying to set up gofundmes for amber
heard and it seems like they might
actually be earnestly trying to do this
and then i'm sure people would try to
take advantage of it
too
i think she's going to end up if she's
smart she will do an only fans and do
and start painting and selling her
paintings but she's also like that's a
ridiculous uh painting
i think she'll make up for no [ __ ]
no it's not very good hunter is actually
not terrible i'd buy one yeah but um
it's gonna be a long time for just to
pay that money because you're gonna go
to retrial you know there's also well
here's another detail about the the
uh challenging the verdict apparently if
you do that you have to put up the a
bond which is equivalent to the entire
oh so it's like oh you want to be cool
where's the money in case you lose
because that's going to go automatically
oh it's just going to have the money
you know what else is interesting is i
heard this is so this same trial
happened in the uk right in the uk
it you know there's not a jury it's
based off the judge and the judge has
access to certain evidence like uh other
evidence with him hitting her in picture
and stuff and the u.s court of law those
that evidence wasn't allowed in they're
saying that's where and there's a jury
that's what her lawyers of course are
lawyers i think a lot of it's [ __ ]
in fact
and so first of all it's very different
so the the case in the uk is a very
different case it was not johnny against
amber it was johnny and his [ __ ] son
yeah and they called him a what this
[ __ ] called him a wife it was not
front page yeah and so it's very hard to
win libel suits against newspapers it's
almost impossible
[Music]
you can't you can't do it in this
country you will lose all your money
yeah i read that and i thought same
thing i'm like what's coming from her
lawyer who knows what's true she lost
she should stop blaming everybody but
herself they were because i know who's a
celebrity was lying you know who's a
celebrity his his lawyer now they're
saying like every firm
uh the his hot lawyer the female lawyer
they're saying uh she went to some
restaurant she's like treated like a
queen now yeah but they're saying like
every firm in la is like throwing her
huge office i'm sure to represent that's
pretty cool because she'll be the one
everybody hires my understanding of the
the uk thing was that there was like
it's widely sort of mainstream accepted
that there was corruption involved
because of connections to the judge to
the newspaper and these things we go oh
this really wasn't deserved you didn't
need to be corrupt you cannot he you're
going to lose that case every time i
don't say it needs to be i'm just saying
i've i've heard accusations that there
were some
connections that if it were in america
you'd say that doesn't seem like the
most i heard that
but also it's a little ridiculous you
let one judge decide the fate of a man
instead of 12 jurors
like we don't see other countries like
south africa with the oscar pistorius
trial they make their case of like
whether you murdered your girlfriend or
it was like some crazy self-defensing
and
my recollection was it's like one or
maybe like a few of them like three at
max or you know but you go oh they have
a different system and you're not
guaranteed the uk did have a jury system
no uh
yeah in general his trial is just one
judge
yeah you know and that's that's why his
lawyer was like yeah and this judge had
access and he knows what's going on
these jurors didn't these jurors were
compromised by social media and they
think the social media skewed the jury
they also didn't vet certain evidence no
amber metadata ever heard lied you could
see it you the the problem is that when
you lie to a jury like that with that
you know you said you the article wasn't
written about johnny depp and then she
said it was written about johnny depp
there are too many inconsistencies man
correct and she kept looking at the the
jury and they were just like no you're
[ __ ] no you know what she you were
the one who took that video and you
owned the copyright and you gave it to
dmz that's why they were able to post it
in 15 minutes yeah 12 out of 12 jurors
you know it's also like the gig's up
five days later you go to the you go to
the courthouse which you didn't have to
do with your publicist no makeup on to
show them what size cannot stop yeah did
that stuff for everybody is like i
really tried to watch it i really try to
watch it with an open mind i don't like
seeing the destruction of anybody i
don't think she's a good person but no i
agree and look find me one thing that
you told the truth about and everybody
keeps saying it's a setback for women
shut up
yeah she said that yeah it's about the
truth and it's about a quarter there's
some real women that are in marriages or
relationships i think
you're talking about real domestic
violence and the courts are always in
favor of people like her it's very rare
that you're that much of a [ __ ] liar
with such bad lawyers she was just lying
man correct there was no evidence the
opposite of truth because and then when
you say he hit me so many times i lost
count with rings on my finger but you
don't have any [ __ ] bruises you
didn't go to the doctor yeah your fa
your face there's no pictures no what
are we talking about name one claim she
made that was true about him abusing her
they're simply what so people see all
this and then people want to say
whatever they want
a lot of you know how many women went
bad on her you know how many women way
more women than men do you just look at
the support for johnny hurts you know
who's still supporting her which i found
to be pretty hilarious kathy griffin i
saw it too oh it's jose no so is amy
oh i got something for your ass i was
telling uh who was telling this story
check this out
this is in new york post
this um amber heard before the trial
hired an unbiased the number one
uh investigator private eye for
celebrities this is all he does it makes
a living doing this
she hires him before the trial and goes
i need you to find actual evidence of
him
in domestic violence
this and this guy came out on this is on
record he goes i went to this going this
is easy gig i'll make easy money johnny
depp all the years you've been child
actor for how long i'll find something
he goes i went to every damn every
person i've worked for him since he was
a kid till now i interviewed men women
hundreds of people
not one person
said he had domestic violence she took
advantage of him further her career an
actor was responsible for his own and he
he was he goes i went into it being
unbiased i went out when i was like oh
she's screwed and then goes and i also
told her i wouldn't go further with this
he has too much support there's no
evidence of any domestic any wrongdoing
and then he also said i feel sorry for
johnny depp because the reason why after
investigating all this stuff the reason
his nuts so high is because johnny
depp's such a good person people take
advantage of him and he has all these
leeches hanging off of him of course who
do nothing but he pays their bills
non-stop of course
he goes johnny depp's biggest problem is
being a good person yeah that's uh that
i couldn't find another one who said
john abused them
no and the headlines was a great
synopsis of that which is basically like
he told amber uh
you got with him before your acting
career and
johnny she tried to destroy a man and
and and up her profiler as a result look
do you go scroll up gin you see him in a
um convertible miata no go down right
there right there convertible yeah you
see him listen you ruined the joke
that's why you missed the video if you
see him in a convertible miata behind
him dude you got problems no you got
problems you got problems because this
guy's gonna find out the dirt daddy he's
got look at that guy he's gonna see him
vegas in a 97 mazda miata convertible
red
he's on your tail and he can do a mean
card trick yeah dude you better be
careful man
p.i to the stars that's it
yeah what else you got jen give me one
more i [ __ ] take tiger jitsu and
hopefully that russian's not there all
right let me see what you're good a good
one well this one because he's a
douchebag this is a disneyland someone
was proposing to his girl and a worker
there i'll just show you the video
why did he do this
he grabs the ring
oh he's trying to be funny no because
they're not supposed to be on that stage
so this guy's doing his job
oh is that andy ruiz
oh my gosh
yes that's right it's over here she's
gonna be even better oh come on
what a absolute dude that guy is just
getting annihilated
i mean not you know abused but
definitely talk smack about wow that's
like you imagine just let him he was
already there these aren't on stage
out there all right thank you for
watching please get off the stage after
the fact or yes i'm sorry guys
no that's it we're done hey let's end so
we and then we do it let's do it
that guy's an idiot
yeah that's crazy read the room dude
what do you think you give the guy two
minutes to get off the goddamn stage
after proposing his girl you ruined the
moment tell you what he he didn't ruin
though uh one show this wednesday
hollywood improv shopping friends we got
some monsters the boys from
garbage are joining me they just got
passed at the cellar in new york they're
two of my favorite humans in comedy they
are with me this wednesday 8pm show only
i got jeff dye brittany schmidt uh david
lucas we got monsters and then thursday
continues we don't stop won't stop can't
stop brian thursday uh portland oregon
thursday friday saturday i'm in portland
at the helium come get some you'll
probably find me at voodoo donuts and
then san francisco is next week june
17th 18th that's friday saturday only at
the cobb's comedy club in san francisco
fort wayne indiana the trash panda
summer tour continues fort wayne indiana
july 14th through 16th san diego
california lab factory san diego in the
heart of san diego downtown july 21st
through the 23rd then we end it with
baltimore maryland august 4th through
the 6th tickets at thickboy.com
best of drops right now today best of on
youtube um i got omaha nebraska this is
what youtube what youtube uh brian
callan you're brian kellen's youtube
it's on their best yes yes and it's
gonna be everywhere it's you hunting
anacondas it's me it's me it's this is
the american top team episode yep where
i i i
quote unquote spar with dustin poirier
things get crazy you hunt anacondas
naked anaconda hunting uh python hunting
is next oh that's not in this
one you separated yeah we separated
omaha nebraska funny bone june 10 and
11. i'll see you this weekend and that
is it for a while until i'm at the
milwaukee improv july 21 22 23 and then
i got austin milwaukee's new too
milwaukee that'd be fun that'll be the
only one monkey's great must be a great
club i'm excited milwaukee where my dad
is from brown deer i'll see you there
it's actually in brookfield wisconsin i
don't know what that means but it's
milwaukee improv and omaha nebraska this
friday saturday come see me funny bone
all right i hope you guys learned
something love you guys this the
fountain kid we're out